aurora colorado's police chief promises
changes in officer training after black
family's terrifying encounter with
police
eyewitness video shows four kids aged 6
to 17
face down in a parking lot swarmed by
officers
they mistook the family's car for a
stolen vehicle errol barnett shows us
how the police chief of that denver
suburb
is responding to this alarming incident
any person watching that video it had to
be disturbed
i don't know how these kids are ever
going to trust the police again
it's an incident rattling the aurora
community and horrifying police chief
vanessa wilson
they never should have been put in that
situation and they've never been should
have been treated that way
[Music]
on sunday officers forced britney
gilliam and her family
out of their car at gunpoint the four
children
screaming and crying for gilliam ordered
to lie face down on the hot concrete
two of them placed in handcuffs them
kids are not ok
they are never going to be ok that is a
traumatic experience would your kids be
ok after that
wilson says officers followed protocol
for approaching a suspected stolen
vehicle
but she said they need to use better
judgment in these situations
they have to react to the human element
in this and the fact that these kids
were traumatized and crying and calling
for their mother
we should have stopped that that call
and and
done something differently the
controversy follows the death of 23 year
old elijah mcclain
last year aurora officers detained him
after they say he was acting
suspiciously
they put him in a choke hold and
paramedics injected him with ketamine
he died several days later the
department later banning the use of that
neck restraint
the scene from last weekend mirrors
another incident in washington dc
last month when a secret service cruiser
rammed into a parked vehicle
carrying two black mothers and their
kids
the mother's alleged agent pulled a
rifle on them
saying their car had been flagged as
stolen and that the suspects were two
black men
one mother says she showed proof she
owned the car
once they knew that there were um
children in the back they should have
been like
guns down guns down these are not the
two black men that we're looking for
exactly
people want officers and law enforcement
across the nation to be held accountable
i totally agree with that
now the secret service says it is
conducting a
fair and thorough investigation of that
dc incident
going on to explain that it was informed
that a person who had once driven the
car
should be considered armed and dangerous
now as far as
aurora and its police chief vanessa
wilson she's led the department for
seven months
and shares that she has personally
reached out and apologized
to brittany gilliam and her family also
passing along the note that the city
has offered to pay for their therapy
jericho
wow eriland that's big because you
wouldn't normally hear about that
happening but i think we're in a moment
where people realize the traumatic
events and the impact that it could have
errol thank you